c'est jour de fête à l'hôpital c'est
joseph d'orange en californie patients
qui s'est battu pendant 45 jours contre
le corps d'un virus est guéri et vient
de recevoir son congé
alors on a convoqué des mariachis pour
l'occasion une image cependant trompeuse
car en cette journée nationale des
infirmières les travailleurs de la santé
aux états unis n'ont vraiment pas le
coeur à la fête et willi balz ça va
vraiment mal résume l'ancien patron du
centre de contrôle et de prévention des
maladies
cela équivaut selon lui au pire moment
de la grippe espagnole
il y à 100 ans et il prévient ce n'est
que le début
as bad boys band the beginning certes la
situation s'améliore à new york mais 230
morts par jour cela reste le double du
nombre de décès habituel toutes causes
confondues aux nombreuses crises jusqu'à
8h et surtout selon le gouverneur andrew
cuomo
l'embellie à new york est annulée par
les os
ailleurs dans le pays angop
outre new york le nombre de nouveaux cas
quotidiens est en baisse dans une
quinzaine d'états comme le new-jersey le
massachusetts le michigan mais la
situation se détériore dans une
vingtaine d'états dont plusieurs comme
le texas et la géorgie ont mis fin au
confinement une erreur aux yeux des jo
comme haïti times c'est l'homme plus
pressé de rouvrir les commerces et de
relancer l'économie
c'est lui qui on ne peut pas fermer le
pays pendant des années dit donald trump
il faut faire quelque chose
il faut dire que 30 millions
d'américains ont perdu leur emploi au
cours des dernières semaines
le taux de chômage pour avril devrait
frôler les 20%
du jamais vu depuis la crise des années
30 une réalité qui fait mal pour un
président qui tente de se faire élire
dans six mois et qui avait fondé toute
sa stratégie électorale sur la bonne
performance de l'économie
mais le virus est têtu et reste sourd
aux impératifs politiques du président
alors la maison blanche doit s'ajuster
après avoir annoncé la fin prochaine du
groupe de travail sur le coronavirus
dans notre homme doit se résigner nous
le gardons ville président un changement
qu'il justifie non pas par l'importance
ni l'efficacité du groupe d'experts
mais par sa popularité jean-françois ça
donne l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
d'improvisation pourtant c'est de plus
en plus clair cette élection
présidentielle sera un référendum sur la
gestion crise du dow jones revient
effectivement vu de l'extérieur on peut
avoir du mal à trouver de la cohérence
dans les multiples déclarations dans le
chapeau au sujet de ce corona virus là
c'est vrai que les contradictions sont
nombreuses jour sur l'autre dans les
faits ça dépend beaucoup de à quel
conseiller il a parlé en dernier qu'est
ce qu'il a entendu aussi qu'est ce qu'il
a vu qu est-ce qui l'a entendu sur sa
chaîne fétiche fox news
mais dans les faits dans le tromper d'un
mobile et par une chose sa popularité et
ses chances de réélection il ne veut pas
être le président d'un seul mandat et la
réalité bas c'est que ça se présente mal
pour lui dire qu ils les sondages
donnent perdant face à dubaï donne au
niveau national mais aussi dans les
états clés qui ont permis sa victoire
contre hillary clinton en 2016 oncle oui
ce conseil la pennsylvanie le michigan
alors il est absolument essentiel pour
lui crucial de relancer l'économie de
remettre les américains au travail
il a six mois pour le faire il faut
aller vite donc même temps il est très
conscient aussi que la levée prématurée
du confinement peut mener à de façon
presque automatique un nombre plus élevé
de morts il ne peut pas se permettre non
plus donc
de voir une hécatombe d'ici la fin de
l'été et donc c'est le dilemme auquel il
est confronté en permanence et c'est ça
qui peut expliquer en fait les multiples
revirements auquel on assiste alors il
ya encore du temps verdict en novembre
merci beaucoup jean-françois à prévoir